the needs of our planet were greater
than she could supply so we went beyond
the reaches of our atmosphere
the new frontier offered the promise of
a new beginning but the distance gave
way to a movement with no connection to
the place we call home new rules new
ambitions
new enemy
the settlement defense front build an
army and broke away from the earth with
blood and violence
they aren't revolutionaries they want
absolute power
they raid colonies take resources and
control territories by force
they use their fleet to block us from
raw materials we need to survive their
mission is to erase everything earth
born
today the SDF is a war machine ruled by
its military
if a leader United that force
they would mobilize try to take our
homeland
oh this is scar one standing by for
tasking copy one one one of our weapons
facilities is under attack by the SDF we
believe this is part of an operation
codenamed to prior Intel suggests their
target is a prototype weapon your team
will extract the prototype and torch the
site before SDF can locate it understood
warlord we'll get it done one minute
friendlies facilities done we get our
weapon torture site key check oma
systems of engagement weapons free 10
seconds
star charts
16300 line we're gonna move creep up its
Gaza boots on ground
I get your dog is belonging moves down
Sarge take point one one to repine set
that gun is in the area of troops in
contact
every points 30 minutes dead help keep
moving Reba
we're approaching the entryway bad boys
we've encountered steady SDF presence
centuries on the roof we'll take one
week or the others
there's the Air Force weapons no
prisoners
multiple target Sneaky's out copy that
man our weapons in the armory fall and
have a clique up
you think not a blaster
assuming they did let's give him a
proper welcome this
those energy grab copy that what's your
corners
raper bernard a moving to the armory
copy be advised SDF is almost inside
operation riot cannot succeed was so
open is secure i could annotate the
self-destruct sequence
goofy eyes on research lab armory should
be next
that's our mark
contact
papers movement
stay look we don't clear kuzey light him
up
we're gonna target now extra bucks March
out weapons on the other side we bake
into it sites crash it all clear
repo we're inside the armor moving to
secure the weapon is in the vault was a
security the self-destruct sequence
weapons beyond those doors
put it up sighs we're gonna need it wolf
bottle psych tech the right operation
more after this Reaper
weapon secure confirming execute order
and self-destruct copy we're Oscar Mike
I made five corpse taking let's move
catcha bradstreet initiating how many
did you come wait
what about the airship we shot that when
they need medical you care about him
clouds judgment that is why do you tell
with
what is raya unclear helmet-cam stop
transmitting it's been 18 hours no
contact set defamation no demands
settlement defense front doesn't make
demands they planted a flag in our rock
they executed three men and shot down a
pilot our team was sent to secure
classified weapons from a close four
silhouette facility is a black site
Admiral
why the hell is set deaf allowed in that
airspace by permission of the Accords
all nations have access to certain that
objective required a full strike force
not a four-man team lieutenant Reyes I
implore you to use diplomacy in this
office take a different tact yes sir
who else knows about this right now
joint Strategic Air Command and you this
is a deliberate act of aggression Hadra
we should be out there on patrol not
down here to throwing confetti the rules
of engagement prohibit definitive action
under these circumstances so we stand by
with our barrels in the Sante we watch a
Fleet Week parade lieutenant Reyes make
no mistake my instincts which are
aligned indelibly with your own are that
we need to engage
why don't we sir they're politicians
Reyes no wife hell's asked with whatever
flag keeps the smokestacks burning -
these men the idea of mounting an
offensive triggers a fresh and unplanned
piss until there's war the Warriors are
in charge what sir by the time there's
more it's too late hesitation is a hole
in the head you drilled that into us
relentlessly in flight school work the
problem respond you are always a fast
learner lieutenant Stratcom is well
aware of our grievances at this time no
use of force is being considered on an
operational level these are the laws of
war son thank you for the briefing sir
Marines III n is in position on the roof
thank you Petty Officer what is III in
go take a look for yourself
I think you'll be quite impressed
dismissed
you